Hello, everybody. Dr. Kevin Conner is again. It is April 25th, and we have actually a truly beautiful day here in Minnesota.
So I look out the window. The sun is shining. It's 67 degrees, which is right on par for April.
Considering a week ago, we had about 15 to 16 inches of snow. So it's a real blessing of a day.
Today, we're going to talk about inflammation, the good and bad and inflammation.
It says positives and negatives. Just like anything that goes on in your body that we've spoken about multiple times.
We don't want to label anything. Oh, that's good or oh, that's bad in a sense because you know, there's good and bad.
It's about balance. So inflammation has its purposes. So in this picture, when you smash your hand with a hammer,
inflammation has its purposes to said white blood cells there. That's what inflammation is. Is it, is it immune response?
So inflammation is a response of your immune system to kill bad things. So if you had severed yourself with a knife,
inflammation is going to be there to bring white blood cells to kill any bacteria that could have entered through that knife food or to help heal damaged tissue.
What we're talking about the bad thing about inflammation is chronic inflammation.
So chronic inflammation could cause cardiovascular disease and cancer and etc.
So that's what we don't want to have is chronic ramped up inflammation.
And that's what we're seeing more and more in today's society because of different factors because of toxins that can't exit the body.
So we talk about what Dr. Hollywood had a talk a few weeks ago about phase 2.5 when you can't get your poisons out of your body.
From your exposed to higher amount of toxins to histamine issues and genetic issues that you can get rid of inflammation.
Cause these ramped up inflammation and that ramped up inflammation that a chronic state causes issues.
That effect the next slide shows that it is that inflammation has an initiation phase and then a resolution phase.
The problem comes in is whether that resolution doesn't take place and we have this chronic inflammation.
Now anti-inflammatory medications work in that initiation phase.
So tanky anti-inflammatories and sands and biologicals and even the steroids reduce the cytokines, kibokines and classic immune markers of the inflammation.
So it does reduce the inflammation.
Oh boy, we're going to feed back here.
So I don't know if you can hear me, we're going to pause this a second.
Okay.
Okay, so I'm going to end the meeting you guys and have to restart it because I'm getting feedback of everything I talk.
I don't know if you can hear that but I hear myself twice.
So I'm going to hold on maybe if I do this.
Okay, well, I didn't have to end the meeting.
So we are recording again.
So everybody is muted again.
That was the issue we had one person that wasn't muted, so I apologize for that.
So back here again, medications that reduce inflammation do work to reduce inflammation.
If you go on a steroid, boy, your inflammation will drop dramatically.
What we're going to find is the way a steroid or a done steroidal anti-inflammatory drug or the new biologicals work is they reduce that immune response.
Well, isn't that what we're trying to do?
Yes, but we're going to talk about the dangers of that as well.
So we're going to talk about the dangers of reducing all the immune cytokines and the T cell response is that you increase the risk for cancer, be it on a steroid because you need to have an immune response.
We don't want this chronic inflammation.
We also don't want to shut down all of our T cell response because we're going to be more susceptible to chronic infection.
And we're going to be more susceptible to cancer because what do we need to fight cancer, but a healthy immune system.
But we have too much inflammation to thought as well. Let's go on an anti-inflammatory.
But if we go on a medical drug anti-inflammatory, it shuts down the T cells, the things that help kill cancer and help kill infection.
So we're more prone to chronic infection, and we're going to be more prone to continued cancer if we already have cancer, a decreased ability to kill cancer.
We have cancer, and it increased risk of cancer if we don't have diagnosis of cancer.
So we don't want to use medical anti-inflammatories to decrease this chronic inflammation.
This is what we're going to be talking about in this talk today.
This new pathway, and we'll skim over this really quick, because I know it's a lot of orange in here.
But this, the pathway of inflammation is actually quite explicit in the way that the inflammatory markers, the white blood stem cells themselves, will create an enzyme.
These are the enzymes that we're talking about here, in the black here, that create this new product that they just discovered called that have been termed Resolvins.
Resolvins, meaning that they resolve an inflammatory state.
There's E-series and D-series and there's others, but these E-series and D-series have been both studied.
So the EPA's and DHA's are what are creating these, these Resolvins that reduce this inflammation in the long run.
So what a person is deficient in these, it doesn't enable the immune leukocytes to create these Resolvins.
So we're going to talk about some factors that we could do from a dietary standpoint and from a nutritional standpoint that can help reduce the bad part of inflammation without reducing the good part of inflammation.
So that's what this SPM stands for. It's called specialized pro-resolving mediators.
That's what these things are, these E-series, Resolvins, and D-series, Resolvins.
And they're made by these pro-resolving mediator enzymes and we're going to show you how it's made so that we could intervene.
So SPM's, these specialized pro-resolving mediators, limit leukocyte production, down-regulate inflammation without decreasing T-Lymphocyte production.
What does that mean?
Well, think of the T lymphocytes as the guys with the machine guns that are out into the bloodstream that are killing cancer cells, so the cancer cell situation.
So we want these guys to be around, we want these guys to kill cancer cells.
But we don't want too many leukocytes causing a chronic inflammatory state because a chronic inflammatory state decreases by lymphocytes ability to get at the cancer and kill the cancer too.
So this is where inflammation could be both good and bad at a cancer patient.
Well, we want the pro-inflammatory cytokines that are creating T lymphocytes, but we don't want too many leukocytes causing just increase, increase fluid production blocking the ability of the lymphocytes to kill the cancer.
Sounds complicated because it is.
So if you're lost, still follow with because if we get to the last slide, that's all you really need to know.
They found that these resolvings, these specialized pro-resolving mediators are actually made in human tissues.
So when they discovered them as a byproduct of what is made by the immune system themselves, they started looking for them and they found, wow, they're very made in all these different tissues at different rates.
So they thought, wow, this is really cool. We didn't know anything about this.
And so they started looking at how it's broken down and how it's created with these enzyme systems from DPA in an EPA. So it's pretty interesting.
They also found that in certain cases of patients, these are cases in the red here are people with severe cardiovascular disease, they make a whole lot less than someone who doesn't have it.
So people with severe cardiovascular disease don't make very many of these resolvings.
So this is so they end up with chronic inflammation. They also end up with chronic monocyte activation, but that's a whole other talk.
So that's where these people with chronic inflammation that you start going, well, why are they, if your, if your white blood cell system is supposed to be making these mediators to break down this inflammation?
Well, in certain people, that's not happening.
So resolvings, this is kind of a neat slide if you get into it affects the epithelial cells to help increase clearance of dead tissue.
It works on dead clinic cells to decrease migration. This is very important with cancer patients decrease IL 12 production, which is an inflammatory cytokine.
It increases macrophages, and that's what we want with cancer cells. We want macrophage activation to help kill the cancer, which increases phagocytosis.
Phagocytosis is a picture with a macrophage simply surrounds like a virus and destroys it and gobbles it up.
So this is what we want to take place. It can be helpful to decrease it if capapeta, which is an inflammatory cytokine as well.
So then they started looking at where are these things made? Is there neuronal control? Is this the nervous system have control? Because again, we found this a normal tissue.
So these are made in normal tissue when it's not even an inflammatory state. Is there some control factor over this?
So they looked at the nervous system and what's possibly controlling it? They found that the vagal nerve, cranial nerve, can that comes out of the ponds?
This is the mid braid here, your spinal cord down here. This is your braid.
So it comes out inside your braid, cranial nerve, tin or the vagal nerve, goes to different organs and you've heard of the vagal nerve.
If you've listened to any of my talks in the past because the vagal nerve controls the parasympathetic system.
And the vagal nerve is what we're trying to stimulate when we do coffee edema.
So I've said before that when you do a coffee edema, why do I do a coffee edema? That was on the Facebook page this week.
Why do I need to do a coffee edema for having a couple good bowel movements today?
We're not doing a coffee edema to stimulate a bowel movement. We're doing a coffee edema to stimulate the vagal nerve.
What the vagal nerve does is it helps stimulate the liver detoxification and that's what you've read about in Gertian's work.
Do a coffee edema because it helps with liver detoxification. Well, it does far more than that.
So the vagal nerve stimulates a lot of things.
The vagal nerve is your main nerve or your parasympathetic nervous system.
And it offsets sympathetic nervous system stimulation.
So there's a balance there between sympathetic and parasympathetic.
Remember, your sympathetic is your fight or flight response.
So you just heard you have cancer. Your sympathetic goes through the roof.
Your parasympathetic inversely goes down.
And it's your parasympathetic that we need to help move the colon, help move toxins out of your intestinal tract, help move toxins out of your liver, help stimulate resolve and production.
So all we're talking about here is goes back to the parasympathetics again.
Goes back to the vagal nerve stimulation. Goes back to another reason why we would want to do coffee edema.
Why we'd want to do other vagal nerve stimulation because it's stimulating this resolve and production.
They found that stimulation of the vagal nerve when we talk about resolve it stimulates this this neuronal tract in your you have this fat layer right city right ahead of your intestinal tract.
And that is called your greater momentum that stimulates that nerve bundle in your greater momentum to release acetylcholine acetylcholine works on what's called group three lymphoid cells and creates this this PCTR which is protecting conjugates of tissue regeneration.
And this is what helps regulate tissue resolve resolution tone regulates backrified fetotype very, very, very important with cancer patients.
And the resolution of infections by stimulating this the the production of this resolving so very important things PCTR mediate peripheral backrified responses.
This is what we want with our cancer patients we wanted we want to increase macrophage response on the cancer.
So it was this again to help stimulate the vagal nerve to produce this response.
So when I looked at this study the study understand was all about how to help people with chronic inflammation reduce chronic inflammation without taking medications to do so.
And so I looked at the study and go wow this is exactly what we need for our cancer patients oh my gosh this fits with cancer so perfectly so we're taking this and extrapolating this data to use with our cancer patients.
Therefore the vagal nerve is key to a macrophage response and a macrophage response is key to helping you with overcome cancer.
So hey with me we're almost to the end so this is anti-inflammatories using current medication there's a lot of drugs that will do it that works on this initiation phase can make doctors a lot of money but it does injure the patient and it is very wrong for our cancer patients.
Using pro resolution mediators and stimulating that is the way to go and here's a slide that we created to talk about how we could do that and if you're watching this video and you want some of the data and you want to look up the studies go ahead and look up the studies on this.
That's our ways to stimulate these specialized pro resolve mediators number one we talked about in this presentation is vagal nerve stimulation and on the Facebook page when I post this video I'll post a form that you could download that talks about vagal nerve stimulation exercises I've given it to a lot of patients but there are some specific exercises that have been proven to help stimulate the vagal nerve.
So we talked about coffee in of us that's one of them but that's not the only thing that you could do to stimulate the vagal nerve so in there there's some neurological things that a lot of functional neurologists do to stimulate the vagal nerve.
Secondly is decreasing sympathetic tone well if we're stimulating vagal tone which is stimulating parasympathetic that aren't we start we enhance it heads decrease in sympathetic tone yes but we could in turn work on decreasing the sympathetic tone decreasing the sympathetic tone is having to really start to deal with my stress.
So when I start to deal with my stress in my life and confront it to get it out and have a healthy avenue to get that out that's going to decrease by sympathetic also we have to look at the sympathetic nervous system where that's housed so the Vegas of the parasympathetic is housed in the mid braid and the puns part of the mid braid the sympathetic is housed in another part of the mid braid called the best cephalon.
So I have another exercise sheet that are exercises to reduce the best in cephalon the big word that's where the sympathetic nervous system originates so that's where the sympathetic nervous system originates so that exercise sheet is called reducing best in cephalic tone or something like that.
So I'll post both of these on the Facebook page and you think, well why don't you just put on one sheet because they are different so we could work on reducing sympathetic tone and we are inversely increasing the vagus and we could work on increasing the vagus and we are inversely decreasing the sympathetic but you're working on two completely different nervous systems there and both of them doing both of them can be beneficial.
So working on increasing vagal tone and decreasing sympathetic tone is going to help increase these specialized pro-resolving mediators which again why are we doing this?
Decrease the bad inflammation and increase the the the work of the macrophages and T lymphocytes or increase the good inflammation so we want to decrease the bad and increase the good.
Also from a dietary supplemental procedure is adding DHAs and EPAs and paratoils from fish oil, coconut oil, walnuts, chia seeds and understand I have you guys do what it all is already.
So but be that up maybe continuing to work on it, this is what you'd see a lot of the ketogenic type diet but even if we're not on a ketogenic type diet we could still be adding these good oils because that stimulates this whole system.
Also, NADH is a co-factor for the resolve in E1 creation. So NADH we have a product called pro NADH and you could take a couple of those a day that's a good product to add that will increase the SPMs.
Also fasting, we've talked about fasting a lot in its many forms, doing the fasting mimicking diet, doing a timed restricted eating type diet is the really the way to go.
So I'm only going to have a window of five hours and I'm going to eat or six hours and drop it to four hours in a given day or doing the fasting mimicking diet so I'm really just really resetting my system.
That is a great way to reduce the bad inflammation while preserving the good.
So this is a good start. I'll post these sheets on the Facebook page in a little bit. Start working on these things.
Anybody can add the NADH. I don't have a problem with anybody doing that. You cannot do fasting if you're in a rapid weight loss where that could be an interest to you.
So the question is, could I add turmeric and CBD oil and such like that? Yes. So turmeric and CBD oil and Boswellia and Ginger. I should have put that in here too, but I made it assumption that I didn't think about it after that.
But those will not reduce your T cell formation and not reduce your macrophages. So they don't have the same effect as, you know, be done a steroid.
So steroids, shut your immune system down. So think of that. Steroids and done steroids, shut your immune system down, meaning they shut all the good guys and the bad guys down.
So that's the harm in that. Whereas the curcubid and Boswellia, Ginger and all your natural quote unquote anti-inflammatories don't do that.
So they all preserve the T cell and macrophages while helping reduce the leukocytes and basophiles.
So I get to open it up to questions. So you don't have to chat anymore. I'm going to unmute everybody for a minute and then we'll get some questions.
What about after surgery, the medical profession is always pushing to take the anti-inflammatories because it's, you know, to help you.
So after surgery, they want you to heal, right? And they don't want too much inflammation because they just cut you open, right?
So they put you at an anti-inflammatory to help you with the healing. But again, it is shuddy. Don't you want to make sure you don't have a secondary infection? How many people after a surgery die of or hospitalized for a secondary infection post surgery?
Very high amount of people, right? And you'll find in these studies, if you go back and dig in them, that when you, that that whole macrophage where one of the slides here and they kind of zipped over the piece where it's a where it's a healing where it's very important for for tissue healing.
I did, but it's so if you reduce the entire system, you're going to lose that that healing property as well.
So we don't want to reduce the entire system. We want to preserve the macrophages. We want to preserve the T lymphocytes. Any other questions? They don't have to pertain to what we spoke about.
I have a question about the time restricted eating. Is it also inclusive of when to take the supplements and like the perfusion drink that that should also be within the four to six hours span of time of eating?
I don't know all the studies on that. You may, the perfusion drink, I would say, yes, it should be in your window of eating.
Some other supplements, possibility. For the purpose that we're doing it, I don't know that we have to be that stuck on it.
So I still think we're going to get the benefit if you're taking a curcuit at six o'clock in the morning with the glass of water and versus waiting till your window. So no, I don't think we need to be so concerned about that.
Okay. Thank you.
Dr. Connors with the time fasting. Should that be done every day? It doesn't have to be.
So it just like this what we're talking about, you know, we're, this is going on all the time.
You know, and the more inflammatory markers in your body and the more things that you're exposed to that are going to be pro inflammatory, like toxic exposure that that you're going to want to do it more frequently, like the restricted fast eating that the vagal stimulation and all is everything we spoke about.
So if you're, if you're stress level is way down and you're feeling great, well, maybe you only want to do this so the weekends or something like that.
But I would suggest you do it every week.
For most people, it could be done on a daily basis, depending on where you're at with your, with your disease process and how you're feeling.
It would be fantastic. Drop it down to every other day or every third day.
But do stick to it. Don't give it up because you're, even though maybe you're living a less stressful life or you're not, you think you're supposed to less about a toxins.
You know, you're still exposed to even, you know, more toxins that you're great grandparents, wherever exposed to in 50 years of living.
Just be aware of that anything else.
No, you're going to, you're going to get me off easy tonight.
I think I got a few other people muted here that muted themselves.
Okay. Well, then we're going to be closing in a half an hour. So that's all right.
Well, I will post this out, save this and post it up on our Facebook page and post those sheets on vagal stimulation and methods of folic.
Reducing exercise is as well.
And we will see you next week.
All right.
Bye bye everybody.
Thank you.